bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france alors pourquoi des
restrictions sur le vaccin d'astrazeneca
s'agit pas de restriction il s'agit de
prudence en réalité les la phase
d'expérimentation qui a été conduite n'a
pas compris de sujets très âgées pour
des raisons qui sont sains dans les rues
habituellement utilisés en europe et par
conséquent faute d'avoir des données
suffisantes sur un nombre important de
personnes âgées l'autorisation
européenne pour ce vaccin astrazeneca
est pour l'instant limités à des sujets
de moins de 65 ans ce qui permet
d'ailleurs de soigner les de vacciner
pardon les personnels soignants et donc
de disposer des vaccins father who
moderna qui aurait été utilisée pour ses
personnels soignants et bien de les
vacciner avec l'astra zeneca d'utiliser
les quantités des vaccins arn chez les
personnes plus âgées donc de retrouver à
peu près le rythme normal c'est pas une
restriction parce que dès qu'on aura les
données dès que on aura suffisamment de
patients observés puisque dans certains
pays c'est utilisé notamment en
grande-bretagne bien entendu eh bien on
l'agencé européenne du médicament lèvres
à la restriction dès lors qu'elle sera
suffisamment documenté chez les sujets
au delà de 65 ans et même au delà de 75
ans alors la campagne de vaccination
auront lieu est très critiqué en
certains reprochent à l'union européenne
d'avoir trop tardé à conclure des
accords de pré commandes de vaccins avec
les laboratoires pharmaceutiques pour
cela avance d'un alien s'en est défendu
aujourd'hui pour elle ça s'explique
seulement par une pénurie mondiale de
composants via la fabrication de ces
vaccins est-ce que selon vous il n'y a
que ça fondamentalement ce que dit la
présidente de la commission européenne
est indiscutable il se trouve
qu'effectivement les uns et les autres
des pays qui ont reçu les vaccins avant
nous avaient largement financé au delà
du paiement des unités financer la
recherche
si le cas aux etats-unis c'est le cas en
grande-bretagne qu'à financer largement
la mise au point du vaccin
astrazeneca l'université d'oxford c'est
le cas de pays qui ont pris les devants
en participant financièrement non
seulement à la pré commercialisation
la recherche est assez légitimement
naturellement les gens qui ont reçu de
fortes sommes voire de très fortes
sommes pour mettre au point ces vaccins
ont une forme de priorité pour le reste
ce que dit ursula von der leyen est tout
à fait conforme à la réalité ensuite il
ya les calendriers de vaccination chaque
pays de robes recevant la quantité
proportionnelle à sa population mais
appliquant le vaccin suivant un
calendrier dans les autorités de santé
puisque je vous rappelle que la santé
n'est pas une prérogative européenne au
rythme qu'elle a choisi aux populations
qu'elle a choisi de vacciner en priorité
alors que généralement pour quelles
raisons tout des laboratoires accuse du
retard dans la livraison de leurs
vaccins est ce que c'est parce que les
états ont trop commandé les laboratoires
ont répondu favorablement sans
réellement anticipée alors partiellement
votre question on peut l'interpréter
comme vous le faites
la raison c'est que finalement on est
passé d'une phase et on l'a bien vu en
france par exemple de grandes réticences
un plus de deux tiers des français ne
voulaient pas se faire vacciner a au
contraire un grand engouement
or finalement la mise au point d'une
usine des différentes phases de
production des vaccins en particulier
les vaccins totalement nouveaux que sont
les vaccins
by one take five year et moderna
nécessite une un agrément non seulement
la la construction d'unités de
fabrication et de conditionnement
spécialisés mais un agrément de ces
ateliers par les autorités de santé les
différents pays et finalement la
procédure d'agrément est longue et
délicate s'agit pas simplement de faire
une inspection rapide et à l'issue d'un
tour de deux ou trois heures d'un
atelier de tamponner c'est ce sont des
procédures de vérification et de
contrôle qui pour certaines prennent
plusieurs semaines plusieurs semaines
veut dire plus d'un mois dans certains
cas et lorsque l' usine de perth en
belgique qui appartient à pfizer et qui
aura en charge les deux dernières phases
du fai fabrication du vaccin biotech
pfizer a souhaité agrandir pour répondre
au mieux à la demande importante et bien
il a fallu attendre non seulement que
les travaux soient faits quelques jours
mais que l'agrément soit donnée ce qui
encore une fois prend du temps au fond
le succès de ces vaccins explique le le
délai que mettent les unes de ses
productions à s'adapter
où que ce soit dans le monde et plus
particulièrement celles qui servent les
clients
bien que nous sommes il est variant même
si les vaccins actuels à 1 sont
efficaces contre quelques unes des
mutations
on peut imaginer qu'il n'y en aura
d'autres des variants peut-être
résistant aux vaccins dans un tel
contexte comment le vaccin peut-il
maîtriser l'épidémie s'il n'est plus
efficace contre les nouvelles souches
alors vous avez parfaitement raison de
mettre tout ça au conditionnel et
d'avoir utilisé plusieurs reprises très
justement encore une fois le mot
peut-être les vaccins arn ont toutes les
chances
plus largement mieux que d'autres la
probabilité d'être efficace parce qu'il
s'adresse en fait non pas à notre propre
organisme mais à la protéine spike la
fameuse protéine qui sert au virus comme
les comme les piquants d'un ours à aller
se fixer sur nos cellules or cette ses
piquants ne varie pas assez ce pack ne
varie pas d'un mutant à l'autre pourrait
imaginer bien sûr qu'ils viennent à
varier mais ça n'a pas encore été
observée ni sur ceux coronavirus ni sur
d'autres et donc ces vaccins très
probablement auront une efficacité du
même ordre que celle qui est déjà
observée avec les aime plus invariants
déjà noté maintenant les vaccins fait
sur des virus atténué par exemple le
virus qui était courant en europe
courant en france il y a neuf mois eh
bien puisque c'est celui là qui est
utilisé pour fabriquer les vaccins de
type classique on pourrait imaginer
qu'il protège moi de là imaginer qu'il
ne protège pas du tout c'est un peu le
même mécanisme qu'avec la grippe et vous
savez que chaque année les laboratoires
producteurs de vaccin de type
conventionnel c'est à dire à base de
neuvy russes tués de virus rendu non non
pathogènes nom capable de déclencher une
maladie là chaque année on se re vaccine
parce que les mutations constantes chez
les virus c'est comme ça qu'il survive
font que il arrive que l'immunité ne
soient pas suffisantes et qu'il faille
se re vacciner il est d'ailleurs estimé
par beaucoup beaucoup de scientifiques
qui travaillent sur le sujet
d'épidémiologistes de virologues de
spécialistes de ces questions que
bien le coronavirus le sarko v2 le
fameux virus qui nous empoisonnent
l'existence à nous tous sur la planète
depuis un an rejoignent un peu ce genre
de virus chronique
c'est du moins ce qu'on peut espérer
assez raisonnablement merci beaucoup
jean jacques brot ski d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
mon médecin hospitalier à l'hôpital
bichat de paris économistes de la santé
à l'université paris descartes martial